already thanks for the opportunity
really appreciate being able to speak
here and even more so really appreciate
a lot of the talks that I've seen and
the hallway conversations i'm at
o'reilly it's actually fairly recent
that I joined O'Reilly just as far as
background I've spent you know about 10
years leading data teams doing mostly
machine learning at scale across a few
different verticals and I've spent the
past after that the past 34 years
evangelizing open source projects
working on cascading mesos and more
recently spark and in particular out of
those I've had a lot of opportunities to
be teaching tutorials and working in
universities teaching in various
programs regarding data science and big
data we spark in particular we had this
huge adoption curve or sorry this huge
adoption rate and we've been doing very
large tutorials all around the world and
I was leading a team that included a
couple people a couple professors from
you see I think Joseph end I'm a tall
Walker who just did the two spark MOOCs
on EDX so you know we we definitely saw
a number of different kinds of use cases
of both in class and remote learning and
in a lot of cases trying to leverage
ipython notebooks or something close so
I wanted to present about where we're
going at o'reilly now with the new or la
learning team which is very much using
Jupiter but also looking at how do we
bring in other types of media channels
other kinds of learning modes and how do
we integrate this in our context as
publisher so who we are O'Reilly
learning is a new business unit and
we're not these people as far as
O'Reilly on we are these people so we
have a lot of books a lot of videos a
lot of conferences a lot of involvement
with developer communities
over the years and you know O'Reilly is
closely associated with with open source
we started to ask on um I just got out
of Oz Khan coming up here the objective
that I was given from the higher-ups as
I walked my way into the door was as a
verbatim examined make sense of and
organize our various training products
and learning channels for ourselves and
our customers and speaking as an author
I've been a writer for a Riley for I
guess the last 11 or 12 years it is kind
of daunting because there's five
different video channels and there's a I
don't know how many different training
channels all these business units that
have been acquired over the years trying
to understand that from an author's
perspective is daunting our editors I
think are probably even more confused
but we're trying to make this something
that's a very cohesive whole how do we
bring these different types of learning
experiences together into something
that's more effective so one of the
first things I've done is to try to
figure out you know just with O'Reilly
as a as a case study what do we have and
how does it work and if I were to try to
put together an overly simplified map of
where the flows are I'm really
interested in charting from an audience
perspective always audience first but
then closely behind that from the
author's perspective the authors coming
in what is their workflow like what
what's the experience that they have and
we're really where are the routes the
different touch points for different
types of media for learning products as
you can see there's several here I've
kind of collapsed a few but it really
spans a range of at the top between
in-person events which often have a very
high transaction cost people will spend
thousands of dollars or their employers
will spend thousands of dollars and
maybe a week out of work to go to some
kind of conference that ranges from you
know a high transaction costs to a
relatively low transaction costs for
on-demand behind a paywall with
something like Safari Books Online and
this process that we have here is I feel
overly complex
it's still regarded as being relatively
agile I don't know if that's really the
right word I kind of I don't like use
that word too much I used to be an
engineering director and I anyway I've
written for a variety of different
publishers and the workflow that we have
here we can put out a book in like six
months generally some of their six to
nine months whereas in a lot of
organizations you know that workflow is
more like two years in some cases in our
case typically you're working with one
editor whereas in other places you might
be working with 12 different editors and
those handoffs all the way across so the
publishing process is really complex and
that's if you're doing a book if you're
doing a book and you're doing a kindle
and you're doing some video to go along
with it and you're going out and doing
appearances it gets oh so complex and
the crux of what I think is a lot of the
problem right now is that when we look
to publish things we generally reduce
them down to epubs of one form or
another and there's probably some video
content that goes in there or can be
linked there but it's a combination of
these two that are basically our source
repository our content source and the
standards for epubs are they don't
accommodate exactly what I'd like to do
in teaching people programming for
instance how to use code so we're
looking at how to react attack this
here's a article that came out last year
and in some conversation with person but
it's called learning architecture it's
actually behind a paywall from Deloitte
but there are some pretty good reviews
of this online publicly available the
idea of learning architecture that was I
think something that's being formulated
in the words of michael pollan you are
where you eat eats and I always try to
keep that in mind in terms of how how do
we provide things for the audience we
have customers we have audience people
who buy books and videos we also have
customers in terms of companies that are
sponsoring conferences and they'll in
some cases sponsored books but they in
turn have customers that they're
accountable to that they're trying to
accomplish something with so I like to
think of that hole
chain of learning so we live within a
community of makers and innovators
learners implementers the objective that
my team has is to come up with a
learning architecture that's very
effective internally but then to
externalize this for our customers and
then apply that as a kind of design
pattern for them to use for their
customers so as far as background I'd
like to point to a article or
presentation from the open data science
conference in Boston recently Kyle Kelly
who's here and Andrew ottawan who's the
CTO of O'Reilly I've worked with them
both in this project over the past year
or so but they had a great presentation
called on demand analytic and learning
environments with Jupiter and in this
they explored a couple of themes one is
the notion of computational narratives
that they were describing of where we
can leverage code in the context of
media and learning experience and into
it speaking from the perspective of
being an o'reilly author before we
always try to put the code first you
know that's what you're taught by your
editor is that when you start out the
first paragraph of the first chapter
show some code get people to dive into
it start to feel comfortable and then
back up from there and start to explain
what's going on in the code so we like
the idea of integrating code as media
into the narrative and there's a lot of
reasons for using these narratives
sometimes they're books sometimes
they're actually being used to surface
insights there's some type of notebook
that's it's showing leaderboards or
other other structure of a community
they may be a white paper or a sponsored
paper they may be an executive dashboard
so we see a number of different types of
consumers of this my experience on this
started a couple years ago when we were
in 2013 we we pitched doing a new type
of book called Jason if math and the
thesis there was teaching advanced math
to business executives in particular so
that people in business would understand
sort of the why and how
of leveraging more advanced techniques
in data science essentially to fund big
data products projects and you know we
find that there's a very big demand for
people who haven't taken three years of
calculus but still want to understand
what is it about graph algorithms what
is it about matrix factorization how is
this going to affect how I have to
manage supply chain in a billion dollar
business unit and the way that we
approached this was to use ipython
notebook for the examples and take code
showing math but then tying it very
directly to a use case that would be
familiar starting from use case first in
the presentation and contextualizing the
problem so that they don't have to have
three years of calculus before they
actually see a use case and while we
were doing that we we did run into you
know very interesting things what we
were going out to conferences and doing
tutorials a lot of it was more on the
operations side but we had a lot of
learnings and I got to work with Kyle
Kelly and Andrew I don't wanna on this
one of the big learnings was this I
thought it Stanford years and years and
years ago and I've taught sense at other
schools but for a lot of my career I had
been a software engineer or engineering
manager and you know then going into
leading data teams and doing more than
eight a scientist role I found myself in
the role of being an author and teacher
with this tool chain that depended on
authors using git and docker and ipython
notebook and software engineering
practices that authors typically don't
touch so it was very interesting to go
back and forth and a lot of that
dialogue with Kyle and andrew is we're
trying to use that to redefine our
workflow for authors one of the things
we were doing was to be alpha testers
for this if you haven't seen it I think
it's very compelling nature magazine
used tenpin be and I Python notebook
essentially the same tech stack the same
code base
they have an article here where they're
taking their peer reviewed articles and
they can ship them out here's the data
here's the code here's the article if
you want to run this you know feel free
and the infrastructure will support you
know 10,000 plus people online at a time
running their own container it leads to
repeatable science it really is in my
opinion a lot of the essence of science
and Jupiter combined with dr. and few
other things in the tech stack are
allowing that kind of open science
repeatable science there was also an
article sort of our thesis statement
from O'Reilly it's by Andrew auto on
that came out in May talking more about
our internal platform that now we're
starting to expose and Tim O'Reilly made
some notes about that here it'll
basically looks like this it's called
Atlas and it's where authors can go in
and put in HTML or markdown or a ski
dock or other types of content now also
Jupiter notebooks we can bring in a
bunch of different content organized it
as chapters and sections etc and it's a
very collaborative environment kinda
like Google Docs you could think of so
editors are in there are you know
changing things are making comments of
what needs to be changed and then it's
all backed by get so the authors can
also be putting in content via pushing
and get and get is already kind of
getting out of the comfort zone for a
lot of authors there's a lot of learning
has to happen but when we start to
combine Jupiter get doc Earth Eve and
other open source projects along with it
it becomes a pretty interesting tech
stack but it's also a fairly unfor
engrams for writers I mentioned this
already but there's something called
phpbb and this is an open source project
it's on github the idea is to be able to
have essentially Jupiter cells as a
service there's a way you can take parts
of a notebook and publish them as HTML
as a webpage so I like to think of it
almost like a three-tier model it's
almost like saying middleware were the
books of the middleware but what gets
provided by thieve is actually HTML
that's for the presentation and in this
way you can do things that you want to
and that you need to in terms of
branding for instance is very strong and
publishing sometimes what we're
publishing is for another entity and
they need to have their logo they need
to have their marketing funnel tied into
it and also it's a little bit better in
terms of instrumentation and some of the
operational aspects of it phebe is a
Jupiter is a moon of Jupiter by the way
and so our proof of concept then is
called beta and if you go to o'reilly
sorry beta or oddly calm / learning in
particular we've got some good examples
some of these actually did not start out
as articles they started out as as I
pregnant notebooks and so for instance
here's one Jake just had an excellent
talk and let me bring up one recent
article so this was a you actually from
earlier this month Jake had article
about pivot tables in Python and here if
you go and you can run it and you can
see it's got a kind of a different skin
it's got a very different sort of
branding and look and feel but these are
notebooks and you could have interactive
graphics with controls etc again we're
just kind of blurring the lines between
what would be classically our content
platform and em project Jupiter okay now
as far as the tech stack on you know
there's the authoring process where
you're iterating with co-authors bring
in content from different sources
working with the editors etc then
there's the production process where you
go through QC and get everything ready
to do pre-press or in this case get it
packaged as a Jupiter notebook in a
docker container and then we can use
Thebe to surface that out to the web
pages of course there's some type of
cloud infrastructure underneath this
typically so the question though is
Billy what's the difference between
authors currently create materials and
this new world where they're using
Jupiter docker Thebe get various types
of clouds to supported etc okay so for
some examples I wanted to point part of
the talk was to try to point out some
good examples of using notebooks in
education and also some other examples
beyond Jupiter to try and compare and
contrast I was really excited to see
what's going on with Microsoft in terms
of Cortana's use of Jupiter I had been
working at data bricks prior to o'reilly
and we're doing a lot of work of course
with notebooks there I'm very much in a
similar similar kind of effort also if
you haven't seen it I highly recommend
something called code neuro this is led
by Jeremy Freeman out of Howard Hughes
Medical Institute janelia farm and this
is a really good one they have a
basically a hackathon for some of the
world's top neuro scientists they get
together for a weekend twice a year and
they are working with Jupiter on top of
spark primarily but then also using d3
and things like that Matt Hamblen is
from New York at a company he's worked
on lightning and thunder along with
spark as a visualization layer really
high performance data visualization
layer that leverages d3 and oj s etc see
what they doing is they have these
intense microscopes and they're looking
at huge networks of neurons firing in
real time off of rats are using lasers
so they don't you know they don't hurt
the rats per se but they're able to get
real-time feeds and process them and
redirect what they're doing in the
microscopes so it's actually one of the
larger use cases for or larger data rate
use cases for spark streaming for
instance but also for data visualization
and again the way that they are sharing
science is based off of Jupiter another
good example one of the other people
involved with this conference is olga
vodník at UCSD
they have a project they're called Yale
lab and again they're they're
bioinformatics is being formulated
around using an iphone notebook workflow
very very similar idea um Lori knows
over there are definitely looking
forward to keynote tomorrow and I think
that out of some of the I want to put
together a list of examples and so I
want to highlight some that are my
favorites if you haven't seen these I
think there's definitely some some great
examples throughout the web there's also
a shared doc that we have we're
collecting uh you know where we're
seeing Jupiter hub being used in
academia also just different use cases
for Jupiter in education and also an
industry to you know taking a look at
some of the companies are being really
innovative about this and so I'll leave
links about that up there I've been
working with Fernando and others on this
or just trying to to curate it let's say
now in terms of compare contrast with
other types of notebooks I definitely
you know give a lot of credit to our
mark down I work for data bricks and
I'll show you an example here if you
haven't seen so data bricks is where you
have notebooks that actually maintain
the state of the analytics you're
working on and then the clusters the
spark cluster is there in the cloud but
the clusters can be attached to detach
within seconds and it's quite different
than usual practice for at one point
eyelid a team that had the largest how
do instance in ec2 and I worked very
closely with Amazon on the the lead up
to elastic MapReduce and the problem
that you see using cluster computing the
cloud is that if you have to launch
hundreds of nodes on VMS it could take
you hours just to get the cluster up and
running um so by leveraging linux
containers see groups are you know you
can instead bring that time down to
seconds and it might be that part of
your analytics workflow requires a huge
cluster 45 minutes and then the rest of
your workflow you know you need one or
two notes aab just to be able to do some
visualization or some
some queries and we see that across the
industry is a very typical pattern so
the depression is trying to leverage
that it's not Jupiter it's their own
code base but I used this for about a
better part of a year teaching in
conferences teaching at universities
also in private corporate training
teaching people to think of applications
by using notebooks and then having them
backed by cluster computing the cloud
here's one where we take a look at
meetups for spark and pull down the data
so that we can put together leaderboards
if who's doing what meetups where who's
sponsoring them what the topics are just
trying to get some analysis of you know
really what what does that community
look like so I'll leave that up another
one I'd point2 if you haven't seen is
Andy petrella and it's called spark
notebook and it's not to piter's use
some of the protocol there's definitely
some some commonality there I've done
some teaching in Amsterdam with Andy and
this is all Scala based but it's very
interesting I a he's iterating on this
very rapidly he's done very nice
integration with docker with Mei sews a
very nice integration of visualization
packages definitely one to track and you
know a couple others as well I know that
Toby was around her earlier on if he's
here now but friend of mine who was at
IBM formerly was sharing with with me
about IBM Knowledge anyhow which is
using ipython notebook hosted in the
cloud softlayer by IBM and of course
mathematic is a great example of they've
been doing this for a long time
mathematically notebooks have had been
out there commercially let's see how
we're doing for time uh there's a few
things that are on my wish list for what
I would really like to see with
notebooks and I hope to be able to help
I hope that our team is able to help
bring some of this about but for us in
terms of publishing video is really
important if you look at the
demographics over
certain age most people don't want to
buy books anymore they buy a kindle and
if you look under that age they don't
buy books anymore they watch videos I
have two daughters who are 11 and 10 and
they go and watch YouTube for anything
they need to learn I I caught them
watching they were trying to modify
minecraft so they need to learn how to
redo the manifests on jar files and they
watched hours and hours if not days of
how to redo jar files and I told them
look I can just give you a build script
but they're like no no dad get out of
here so you know kids love video and we
have to take that into account and
meanwhile we have a lot of conferences
all over the world we have this huge
amount of video content if it could just
be structured and tied together with
other types of learning materials
there's also the social context of
mentoring and bringing in experts on a
problem for some period of time there's
the notion of learning paths how can a
subject matter expert structure of a
program of learning and of course i'll
i'll use the M word there are the remote
learning environments so that leads me
to MOOCs and we just had a very
interesting experience with about a
hundred thousand people signing up for a
couple of mooks that we did or I I was
tangentially involved let's say the UC
professors really did the work hanging
around folks who study MOOCs there are
some some difficulties I think that
they're excellent it for learning at
scale but they do have some drawbacks
number one it's really costly for
authors to go and create a MOOC it's
also very difficult to instrument and a
lot of this especially in industry they
want to see some sort of performance
what are we getting out of this what's
the engagement and with EDX you're just
behind a wall you can't really
instrument it all that well there's very
low completion rates typically typesafe
is a counterexample I understand they
have like about a ten percent completion
rate which is actually fairly rare and
and the other thing is that the social
context if you're trying to teach
thousands of people at a time even if
you're trying to teach hundreds of
people at a time let me draw that back
because I've done that a lot
you need to have TAS you need to have
somebody to help engage in the dialogue
you can't just have one speaker and
thousands of people if you're trying to
a large MOOC you end up having to try to
arrange a small army of TAS and that's
complex in itself so you know there's a
future learning summit at Stanford
recently and I thought it's hilarious
I'll paraphrase Peter Norvig here but
you got up and said that MOOCs were
having huge troubles because of the
search engines and we were like wait a
minute aren't you from a search engine
company but it was a really good point
that you need to get people to want to
interact with the learning materials and
generally that's because of social
context so i'm not sure that i really
believe that a MOOC alone is going to be
the path forward for learning because
unless it has better social context i
could talk more about rubric
particularly ways to leverage social
context but maybe that's for another
time that's a favorite topic now if you
haven't seen it this is a really great
example yes sir Abu Mustafa out of
Caltech does a machine learning program
there it's not EDX they did I believe
one year in EDX but they they had been
doing something prior to that which is
arguably more advanced and really
leveraging the notion of inverted
classroom or you might hear it called
flipped classroom where you know the
students have a lot of materials in
advance they can work through and then
essentially they're they're trying to
build a funnel where the instructor
really has the engagement at points
where it's very critical and can have a
lot of outcome a lot of benefit and in
it is very much kind of the opposite of
what you think of when you're building a
lesson plan for a classroom of 30 people
there are other issues out of their
pedagogical issues in terms of trying to
match the content to the learners needs
and Andrew had a nice paper about this
actually a lot of interactive examples
it's called patterns of code as media
arm and as far as like learning to
program I think there's some great
examples there they go across a spectrum
where is the person on learning curve
where are they in terms of being an
doctor how well do they know the
material not just did they pass the 10
questions on the pre exam so looking at
it in terms of more dimensions it's
really crucial and so you know for that
what our team is looking at is really an
exercise in high-dimensional data arm
taking a look at the spectrum across a
number of different dimensions of how do
people engage with content and what do
they need and why are they doing this
not just throwing an exam at them but
trying to understand where they at with
respect to the topics and therefore what
experiences they have to that note I
think that there are some very good ways
to use machine learning for this if you
had the right instrumentation if you
haven't seen there's great work out of
Stanford you're a leskovec out of MDS
etc and but more more to the point when
it was postdocs Julie McCauley was there
and Julian's from Australia and when he
got to grad school in the US he believes
that the beer was horrible compared to
Australian beer so he started doing
machine learning work to try to
understand why and and he really came
out with some interesting results it
dove tailed with other work that you're
I was doing but basically they said was
with a few different signals and not
that much data but with the right data
you can actually measure the distance
between a person coming into a community
and starting to learn about it and you
can actually get a pretty early
trajectory of whether or not they'll
stick around just even looking at the
language they use and the difference in
the language usage patterns as the
person learns and as the community
evolves and you can start to detect with
actually very good reliability when the
person is ready to leave in relatively
far advanced of them actually leaving
and if you've been involved in online
forums you've all seen this we've all
seen this but they came up with
recommender systems time-based
recommender systems to actually quantify
this and measured distances of a learner
with a community where they're both
evolving and I think this is fascinating
and I trying to put this in practice
again in terms of open source
communities etc I also want to make the
point that
learning curves are forever it's sort of
a Sisyphus kind of example the idea is
particularly in data science my
experience leading data science teams is
that learning curve is the hard problem
and the thing about data sciences you're
breaking down silos your your your
transgressing and crossing boundaries
that if you did not get the data across
those boundaries you would never get the
insights that's that's the big
difference between the prior generation
of business intelligence and what some
of the success stories and data science
have proved but you're always having to
learn about these different domains the
different processes all these different
tools and actually budgeting for that is
really one of the hardest things of
being a manager in data science but
perpetual learning curve is the problem
the way to address that is to borrow
from engineering software engineering
notions of say continuous integration or
continuous deployment and think about
continuous learning there's a great
brief article by Whitney Johnson also
building on one Mendes of looking at
learning curve not just as the
traditional sigmoid transfer curve but
actually looking at as a continuum for
for a continuous process and be equal to
measure and quantify when is it that you
needed to jump from one curve to another
so highly recommend that and that leads
to this point when you look at the sort
of bowling alley curve that Geoffrey
Moore my talk about your it really comes
back from everett rogers the diffusion
of innovation decades ago or should the
year i was born but you know you've seen
this probably where there's the
innovators the early adopters is the
bowling alley where they lead into the
early majority and then the late
majority and the laggards and typically
when we talk about putting the other a
conference and being the program
committee for talks we want to get the
innovators we want to get them doing
keynotes we want to give them doing the
really hot topics but I want to pose the
question in terms of industry in terms
of community where are the experts on
this graph are they the innovators and
I'd love to talk about that more maybe
afterwards I know we have time
constraints but I don't believe that the
innovators are the experts and I think
there's a continuum and
you have to look at sort of a
multi-dimensional perspective of where
is the learner visa V the topic and the
community and the experts show up in a
lot of different places but you can
pinpoint it and we do see that you see
that in our sales figures and I hope to
be able to surface more about that
looking ahead um beyond books because we
have to be moving beyond books in my pin
and Beyond kindle I've gone through the
experience of actually putting the other
mobi from Python scripts manually and
having to deal with all the different
xml conflicting xml formats we need to
get beyond the notion of view pubs and
kindle particularly to be able to do any
kind of interactive content that's
running code are leveraging cloud etc
beyond MOOCs are you know I believe that
the the path forward will be leveraging
learning paths continuous learning and
verdict classrooms I didn't talk much
but computational thinking is very much
out of jeanette weighing and all out of
CMU it's very much the kind of Rubik
that I try to leverage when i'm teaching
also learner segmentation and a lot of
multi-dimensional analysis for machine
learning of how do you fit the content
with the learners and interestingly more
and more we're hearing that it's not
about an individual person learning it's
about their social context once they get
paid to go to a class how well do they
perform how does their team perform
afterwards or maybe you're putting an
entire team through a class for sending
an entire team to a conference but it's
the team outcome that's ever so more
important than an individual's test
score and at the same time though we
still have to do things like
certification and I leading that and
trying to understand where do developer
certificates fit into this picture
because we have to make it a
comprehensive whole and finally I'll say
that we're very eager to work with new
authors on this this is a green field
and what we're doing with notebooks is
essentially displacing or helping to
evolve what had been done with white
papers what had been done with
conference talks what had been done with
MOOCs
and we're inventing this as we go along
with everyone else here at this
conference but I believe that Jupiter is
having an enormous impact and
displacement on these prior modes of
media and going out and talking with
early customers they're extremely eager
to do this nobody knows exactly what
it's going to look like but we're eager
to help invent that future together and
I would invite you to be participants
please let us know if you're interested
armed with that thank you very much any
questions yes yes yes yes that's great
well there's the badges I mean there's
the notion of badges and certainly
better experts in that than me armed
cash in a couple things there that I
would like to say one is I mean a lot of
people when they think about MOOCs the
second thought they have is get a study
group together and that's one thing I've
been trying to analyze and really map
out is you know where some this is
coming from a lot of its ad hoc but some
of it's becoming more formalized through
meetups and things like this so we're
actually looking to try to sponsor or
facilitate study groups for difficult
topics I know some of the books that
come out of O'Reilly I know of one in
particular I want I won't name it but it
the examples are so difficult that
people have to have a study group just
actually run the code and so I've seen
these thriving study groups as a result
and I think that once you get past the
beginner audience the introductory
courses you get past even some of the
intermediate you get in the advanced
topics it's absolutely crucial and so
the social context really reinforces I
got to get past this hurdle or I'm
blocked and I'll give up another one
that I guess I would point out maybe not
as much badges but kind of the
gamification I mean chief Devlin and
others are really good at this but um
Masha said ova at salesforce who does
like training for security at salesforce
has some great talks about this where
the problem that they had if i can
paraphrase it right is
when you're working in enterprise and
you're building these in ginormous Java
projects you know a build will take like
60 minutes so for Salesforce when an
engineer changes some code goes to you
know commit and run through tests
they've got an hour open what are they
going to do are they going to go watch
YouTube probably or reddit or something
like that so what they came up with is
let's have sort of what they were using
actually are you familiar with egg cast
is a sort of mukesh kind of platform I
believe Microsoft is very much involved
in this too but it casts was one of the
platforms that are using and they
basically would structured so they knew
they had that our window while maven or
whatever was running and they they came
up with video-based instruction tied
with get repos so you watch a certain
amount of video that would show you how
to do best practice and implementing a
security feature they give you an app
that runs but it you know has security
holes you have a time window to be able
to fix that check it in pass through
tests and then they have all these
leaderboards on different dimensions so
it's totally gamified so I mean rather
than go play a video game they basically
give you one and that's kind of the
badge notion I think it's kind of
asymptotically out there um yeah I I had
I haven't really had a lot of direct
hands-on with the other areas of
gamification but I have had a lot of
hands-on with group projects and the
peer review the one that I would point
you there I'm blanking his name but I
can look it up after in the break there
was an instructor out of Australia who
did an intro robotics course that was
targeted more third world Africa Asia
Southeast Asia and they had largely it
was based off of peer review the
inverted classroom model is about groups
assessing other groups and sharing with
them and they're even Kickstarter's for
you know groups in Africa to get the the
source materials and so they sort of
gamified the pier parts of it um I
thought that was pretty interesting to I
can get up sorry I don't have a link to
that I can grab them questions yes
Oh certainly yes excellent excellent
school well I mean we have a that is a a
mode of learning a type of channel or
actually a collection of channels that
we have and it has mentoring aspects it
has video aspects it has several
different aspects in some ways it's a
head then maybe some of the other
channels we have I think that mentoring
is key it's just the economics of
mentoring have always been kind of
problematic I participated in various
pilots over time and I would love to be
an independent consultant living high on
the hog by being a mentor from remote
just never quite worked out for me I
think that you know OST is definitely a
big part is picture because we're seeing
that content itself is becoming more and
more about training and training itself
is becoming more and more about
consulting light so there's this whole
spectrum or marketing funnel if you will
where it isn't just about writing a
paper anymore it is much more
interactive and it is much more socially
engaging and I think the OST has a very
good model for that right
there-there's layer
so just to repeat that that's about
software carpentry there was a
spreadsheet that I had a link to that's
actually you know talking with them and
that was actually some of the examples
we were linking to and I you know really
that follows after kind of guild models
and initiative models and I I love that
I'm also involved in something called
data guild out of Palo Alto where we had
some similar notions of leveraging more
the social dynamics as opposed to vc
funding yeah I do think that peer
teaching is really crucial for what it's
worth my teaching fellowship at Stanford
was just set up computer science peer
teaching it's now called residential
education and I think it got it helped
to propagate out to MIT and Dartmouth
and others and I've just seen this
really work well I mean it it's still
going 30 years later oddly enough um how
can we leverage that though online and
you know I I do have concerns I mean
sure you've all seen what's happened at
reddit and other places recently Cora is
another example so whenever we have
something remote anonymous we get in
these online forums there's just such
enormous gaps for bullying or other
types of distortions I mean we see it
with our five-star ratings for
conference talks we see atrocious things
happening last week was actually a
extremely unfortunate example of that so
I have to understand what are the
mechanisms for social reinforcement for
actual beneficial behavior if you will
but I think suffer coffin carpentry is
awesome I'm just sort of thinking out
loud about about that kind of pure
relationship at distance does that
g
yeah yeah
yeah I absolutely I mean I again very
much Greenfield I don't claim to be the
expert in this but I have seen those
kinds of programs and I believe that
there was some over skype i also i
personally i participated in some
language training like pure language
training over skype and and it's great
and I and I look forward to that I also
see that kind of behavior with my kids
interacting with friends online through
skype and Instagram and whatnot so no
I'm really hopeful that I mean a lot of
the social channels can be can be built
out it just I i think that when i see
you know chat forums like we use for
webcast for instance they're fairly flat
we need to be able to make that richer
that's a good one I think we're actually
blown past our time for the talk so in
the interest of keeping the video link
that the sort of the same way we'll go
ahead and maybe soccer but please
encourage I want to come down ask
questions to Paco in a person also thank
you